the gas leak ended months ago but the
answers as to who carried out the
attacks on the nordstream pipelines May
at last be surfacing reports in the U.S
and now the German media suggest an
anti-russian government group based in
Ukraine was responsible
according to the German reporting six
people all carrying forged passports
boarded a rented yacht at the German
port of rostock on the 6th of September
last year the yacht sailed up the coast
to the town of Vikram Das and onto the
tiny Danish island of christianso close
to the explosions that hit the pipelines
on the 27th of September
almost immediately Western Nations
suggested Russia might have sabotaged
its own pipelines to create further
chaos in Europe's energy markets
Russia accused the United States of
being behind it to remove Russian
economic leverage over Germany ethereum
endorsed last month in a report by the
investigative journalist Seymour Hirsch
now these Revelations becoming a major
topic of discussion at Wednesday's
European Union defense Minister's Summit
in Sweden there are ongoing National
investigations and I think it's a right
to wait until those are finalized before
we send him more about who was behind
that has been the line from Western
Nations since the attack last September
some now suggest it was a deliberate one
to Shield Kiev as it sought more
Weaponry from Germany the country from
where without its knowledge the attack
was reportedly launched
I know the reports about this
investigation I read that with great
interest and we have to distinguish
clearly yes whether it was a Ukrainian
group so it could have been on Ukrainian
behalf or a pro-ukrainian one without
the knowledge of the government but I
caution against jumping to conclusions
Pistorius also said it could have been a
Russian false flag operation Ukraine
continues to deny involvement for me
it's a little bit strange story because
it's not this story is nothing with us
and I think that investigation of
official authorities will describe every
details because it's like a compliment
for our special forces but this is not
our activity we put in if this attack
can be proven to have been the work of a
pro-ukrainian group even if not the
Ukrainian state that could still prove
tricky for a German government needing
to bolster falling public support for
its military backing of Ukraine
these latest leaks have emerged well
after Germany pledged Advanced Air
Defense and tanks to Kiev Harry Fawcett
Al Jazeera